hello everybody markiplier here with a
very special Cup coming announcement
first off we hit 8,000 subscribers as of
yesterday which is absolutely incredible
considering we just hit 7000 subscribers
on Sunday so the growth have just been
astronomical which reminded me of why I
do this and why I want to do this a lot
of you who have already been watching my
content for a while knows exactly what
I'm talking about fur butt but for those
of you who are new to my channel and new
to my videos please know that I don't
just want to be another youtuber I don't
want to just be some guy who plays video
games on the internet I want to be a guy
who leads a community that is focused
around building up the world around us
that's focused on improving the world in
every way possible which is why I take
it upon myself to drive certain
initiatives sometimes including my
upcoming 12-hour charity livestream now
those of you who know I've done a 24
hour charity livestream where we raised
over $2,000 for child's play and that
was back when I had about to 2500 3000
subscribers so that was a while back and
nowhere near the numbers that we have
now so I'm really hoping that we can
strive around or not strive but band
together and unite in a common purpose
to try and do good for the world now
it's a 12 hour livestream because as you
know I'm in college right now for
biomedical engineering I don't have a
lot of time on my hands but I really
want to dedicate a chunk of my time to
helping helping everyone I can because
we as a group of people who just enjoy
videos can also be more I always
advocate in my channel that I don't want
to disagree with anyone I don't want to
put people down I don't want to put
other youtubers down I don't want to put
anyone down because we don't need to be
at each other's throats if we can
realize that we can build something even
better
by working together so coming this
Sunday this Sunday starting at 10 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time and ending at 10
p.m. Eastern Standard Time we will be
doing a 12-hour livestream for child's
play and if you don't know what child's
play is there's a link in the
description below that'll lead to their
website they're very reputable charity
organization a lot of gamers donate to
them eventually I'll expand out but it's
very easy to organize and donate
directly to the charity which means I
don't have to handle it if you're new to
my channel and you don't trust me just
yet I look at this face now I wouldn't
trust me either but you don't have to
worry about that the donation widget
will be set up so that we can go you can
just donate directly to them not a penny
goes into my hands which means more for
the charity and also this will be over
on my twitch channel which as some of
you know I live stream before but if you
don't know and you're new which most
likely you are considering it we've
almost doubled these subscriber counts
since I last did it about a month and a
half ago there will be a link to my
twitch channel in the description below
so please click on it and follow you'll
be sent an email as soon as I go live I
will be posting a video on this channel
when I go live and we will be ready to
rock and raise some money for a good
cause so I hope you'll all be there for
this Sunday 10:00 to 10:00 12 hour
livestream this is literally the only
socket of time that I could fit it in
but I'm totally willing to donate my
entire Sunday to just playing games for
you guys and for the kids in need out
there so thanks again everybody and I'll
give more details into the games I'll be
playing and a certain reward system when
we get closer to the day or on the day
itself so thank you guys so much and I
hope you can join me as we try to build
a community that's dedicated to
bettering the world around us and I know
that we can do great things we did great
things with you know just a handful of
people compared to what we have now
think of what we could do with 10 times
the number that we have now
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye